Counter-Strike: Global Offensive is by
definition a first-person shooter. That
means that incredible aim is at the core
of what makes the game so exciting.
(Casting)
But at the top level, strategy is incredibly important too.
Having the right tactics for a map can
be the difference between victory or
defeat.
(Casting)
And map mastery comes in the form
of strategies, often ones that rely on
utility. That means grenades,
flashbangs, molotovs and smokes. All
designed to force enemies out of
position and deny them sightlines.
(Casting)
But sometimes a player will do
something that subverts expectations, and
no player embodies that more than s1mple.
In Counter-Strike there are individuals
that have made names for themselves by
defying conventions. For example, in a 1v1
against kennyS at ESEA LAN 13, North
American CS prodigy Swag threw his
pistol to fake a flashbang.
kenny turned away from the impending
blast that never came, and he cleaned up
kenny for the clutch.
(Casting)
North American CS pro
Stewie2K also famously disregards
expectations of the game. Instead of
cautiously playing around the smoke
like most players, he aggressively pushes
through it. Often catching players who
expect him to be cautious off guard.
(Casting)
But s1mple, known for his confidence and the skills to back it up,
is one of the game's most exciting players.
(Casting)
"There is just a little edge of
something different about s1mple that
makes you think, I actually believe this guy can do anything in the game."
And s1mple, like every great, refuses to accept the limitations of the expectations put upon him
by others. And that's led to some
incredible highlights.
(Casting)
At ESL One New York 2016  —
a tournament s1mple and Na`Vi would go on
to win — he made a fateful decision in a
1v1 against Team Liquid's nitr0.
(Casting)
In a shocking move, s1mple
threw the A-W-P — a sniper rifle worth
$4750 — over the wall into Dust2's B bomb site.
"Sometimes you will see someone throwing their pistol to pretend it's
a grenade. To have people turn around, but
what did he think it was going be an
airstrike coming in with a missile from
the sky? What is s1mple actually doing."
The exact effect this had on the 1v1
is still a matter of debate. It wouldn't
be unreasonable for a player in Nitro's
position to be distracted by the
incoming flying object. Then again he
didn't seem to react too dramatically to
it. But throwing the world's most
expensive flashbang is perfectly in line
with s1mple's audacious nature. He was
preying on others' expectations, and won the duel because of it.
"It was just like fate you know, he's like what the
f*** is going on."
Of course, given the
sheer flashiness of the play, there were
plenty of people who wanted to recreate
it. To varying degrees of success.
And of course, it wasn't the first time
somebody threw an AWP. But it was the
first time it happened on a stage of
this size.
"I think that on the pro level, Tier 1 level, I think that
the fake flash thing works one in maybe
a fifty, or a hundred times even. So him
throwing his gun to do it is just a
more of a psychological thing than
anything else, because think of how much
that's insult to injury to nitr0."
As long
as there's an established way to play CS
there will always be cunning opponents
who exploit these patterns.
(Casting)
And in October 2016,
s1mple reminded us why those
expectations can be a liability — and how
they can let the AWP double as a $4,750
flashbang.
(Casting)